j'accueille maintenant claude brasseur
c'est comme un bon soir denis robert
dont vous venez d'entendre l'interview
en coulisses un garçon soit jeux de
cartes et qu'on ne présente plus eve
angeli votre voisine charme qui cartonne
top 50 qui est alain chamfort qui est
l'un de mes chanteurs en mai mais le
disque préféré voilà cela claude très
bien vous n'avez pas votre montre là non
pas parce que votre père vous avez dit
l'exacte herviou quand on se donne on
donne son temps donc on enlève ça montre
c'est un très bon deuxième alors enlevé
la faites moi plaisir et obéit à mon
pape
voilà un v6 à votre père donc justement
la pièce que vous commencez le 6 février
au théâtre de la porte saint-martin
s'appelle conversation avec mon père oui
donc voilà de herb garde meurt alors
l'adaptation est faite par jean claude
grumberg mise en scène de marcel bluwal
voilà alors l'auteur de conversation
avec mon père c'est herbe gartner qui
est l'un des trois ou quatre grands
auteurs dramatiques américain des 50
dernières années
c'est lui qui a fait des clowns par
milliers qui a été jouée par yves
montand avec beaucoup de succès à
l'époque je ne suis pas rapoport qui
était joué par jacques dufilho et cette
pièce conversation avec mon père et je
permets de le signaler que d'importants
il est quand même bossé un des grands
scénaristes américains
on lui doit hall jazz et la liste de
schindler oui l'histoire c'est
l'histoire d'un père et deux fils l'un
d'entre eux est joué par serge
hazanavicius
vous vous êtes le patron juif d'un
bistrot new yorkais qui a débarqué de
dessin en 1936 sous le nom de isaac
goldberg et qui en fait se fait appeler
et dire hausse mais qui veut s'intégrer
dans la société américaine mais qui
reproche à son fils de perdre ses
racines quoi voilà c'est un peu simple
indien de ces femmes des deux thèmes de
la pièce parce que je pense que dans
toutes les grandes pièces ya toujours
plusieurs thèmes qui sont abordés
or le thème de l'immigration vu sous un
angle très particulier où on démontre la
différence qu'il ya entre la première
génération d'émigrés
et puis les
souvent des générations suivantes et
c'est en général la première génération
éviter ce qui est mon cas ce qui est mon
grade dans dans la pièce touchant les
boeufs changer de non-échange
d'architecturé leçon de nourriture
échange de langage c'est terrible c'est
eux qui défriche tandis que la seconde
génération le jargon ils sont chez eux
voilà lui fait tout pour être américain
alors que ses enfants sont américains
d'ombré d'une femme est le deuxième
thème qui a demandé qui est intéressant
pour ça qui me fait plaisir
la pièce intéresse les les jeunes c'est
le problème des rapports entre un père
et un fils c'est à dire que l'erreur
commise souvent par amour par les
parents ses deux de vouloir pousser
leurs enfants dans la direction qu'ils
veulent eux un sens essayez plutôt de
2,2 de trouver ce pour quoi ils sont
beaux et eon le rôle que j'interprète un
échec complet puisque je voulais que
veut comme fils soit boules de l'ain
devienne la guérite à mike alors il
devient effectivement un véritable
américain un peu stabilisé jeunes
travailleurs gagnant du poignon pu
finalement le m'aperçois que les mecs
qui bossent comme des bains à régler qui
ne dorment que quand ils prennent un
taxi qui deviennent milliardaire sur des
gens qui m'ont merde
de l'autre je veux faire aussi un vrai
américain je veux en faire un héros je
l'envoie à la guerre l'étude ouais donc
deux échecs c'est génial et récentes de
l'échec
ce qui est génial clou de ces cons
vieillissant vous avez vraiment de plus
en plus la voix de votre père et l'autre
jour je vais appeler vous a laissé un
message sur mon répondeur et j'entends à
l'ofce brasseur et d'un seul coup je me
suis j'ai eu l'impression d'être mort
est au paradis et l'entente de pierre
brasseur c'est vrai que chez les
brasseurs la comédie c'est une histoire
de famille on connaît puisque votre fils
alexandre brasseur
bah ça marche très très bien pour lui un
ben j'espère me disant que ça va marcher
ça commence bien
il était dans maigret avec bruno cremer
sur france 2 hier
1 il écrit un court métrage qui raconte
la difficulté de dire je t'aime à son
père mais il dit c'est pas du tout auto
biographique entre l'interview parce
qu'il dit avec mon père cela très bien
on s'appelle pratiquement tous les jours
voilà exact on parler de votre vie
c'était en 1936 à neuilly vous êtes le
fils jett joyeux et de pierre brasseur
vous faites partie d'une dynastie du
théâtre qui remonte à l'époque de la
restauration à hélice en 1820 alors le
premier brasseur c'était le créateur du
théâtre des nouveautés
après il ya eu jules directeur du
théâtre des variétés
son frère albert comédien vedette alors
votre prénom est le vrai nom de votre
père c'est pas brasseur c'est espinasse
oui et là on va parler de votre vrai
grand père qui était un personnage assez
assez extraordinaire c'est que votre
grand mère a eu donc cet enfant avec
monsieur espinasse un qui était pierre
brasseur votre père alors c'était quoi
c'est un gigolo magnifique pour un très
beau mais était très beau et puis ils
demandent ma grand mère qui était
comédienne également mais celle l'énervé
parce que elle se prenait elle était une
artiste mais ça se voyait pas alors pour
que l'on sache que j'étais une artiste
elle avait remplacé son sac à main par
une boîte un violon oui pour moi comme
ça on va me prendre pour une artiste est
là il ya un très beau jeune homme qui
l'a qu'il a fait là couvre dans un
autobus et qu'il est sur l'impériale de
l'autobus et quand votre père raconter
l'histoire jacques brel il la vit dans
le refrain de sa célèbre chanson
bruxelles et il l'invité hier vient me
voir au théâtre alors il veut donner des
tickets elle est allée luan le cherche
encore parce que c'est ni plus ni moins
qu'un figurant hallebardiers qui était
hier que en fait il était il était
l'amant de sarah bernhardt y avait un
théâtre il avait fait croire à votre
grand mère qui est une grande vedette du
théâtre
ce qui fait qu'il a dû excusez moi
l'expression la sauter dans la loge et
que votre père est né pierre brasseur
est né ainsi voilà mai mais un jour
quand mon père jouer qui ne théâtre
sarah bernhardt il mais avec le concert
on a fait tourner et monter mal
les lots et m'anime je sors certainement
d'une de ces loges de la voilà alors
c'était spinasse est mort à 24 ans d'une
cirrhose du foie et votre père t'a misme
ces jeux de terre comme vous a pris le
nom de jeune fille de sa grand mère
c'est à dire brasseur exact voilà alors
votre maire si odette joyeux évidemment
qui a été célèbre par entrée des
artistes par douce par le mariage de
chiffon fin des films descendait les
monuments voilà et quand votre père la
rencontre d'être joyeux elle a 18 ans et
sur le tournage de grisou et l'huile est
séduit par sa fraîcheur
ils n'osent pas la toucher et ça quand
même touché baisse depuis la wii mais
finalement oui oui oui mais même après
le mariage il a considéré comme un
enfant et elle dit dans ses mémoires
d'ailleurs c'est un petit peu difficile
avec pierre brasseur et votre père sur
le plan sur planche charnelle elle dit
nous vivions comme de chasse aux
orphelins ce qui vous a pas empêché
effectivement de naître un an après le
mariage malgré tout claude brasseur la
pause une enfance génial mais vous avez
côtoyé jouvet sarah montand signoret
cocteau kessel viry qui était votre
parent oui bah c'est un peu comme tous
les enfants du monde
c'est à dire que l'on côtoie et on vit
dans le milieu de ses parents est
souvent les les enfants voient les
collègues de bureau bah oui
effectivement les collègues de bureau
nous serons perret des gens que vous
venez de citer jeux du genre connaissant
mon père de sabo ne m'a jamais écarté
faire qu'en fait vous n'avez jamais eu à
rentrer dans le métier
vous êtes né dans le métier quoi
contrairement à beaucoup de gens qu'on
reçoit qui ont eu du mal à rentrer dans
le système
vous vous étiez quoi oui il ya une
statistique officielle et
internationales dès que 70% des enfants
reste dans le même créneau
professionnels pas le même profil même
que nous professionnels heures par an
oui ça me paraît normal on te fâcher les
médecins aujourd'hui chez les sportifs
bien sûr alors vous dites votre père m'a
toujours garder avec moi ils ont quand
même mis en pension
oui un essai très malheureux en pension
et maintenant avec notre ami kersauson
et moi un peu et c'est une
un détail bb6 très désagréable mais bon
nombre de raconter je suis d'une
génération où des adolescents pendant
l'occupation qui fait que je j'avais
peur parce que il faudra des brefs qui
dit peur dit oh dis que j'ai pissé au
lit très tard et au collège devait avoir
une dizaine d'années et à la première
récréation du matin on nous faisait
tourner autour de de la cour de
récréation sous les rires des enfants
lorsque les enfants ne sont pas toujours
tendre avec le drap accroché autour du
cou va mouiller du pipi de l'ennemi
d'alors et mes deux mois les modèles
églises les biens et puis un jour le
jour c'est vrai j'ai les
j'ai voté et il y avait une branche par
terre j'ai attrapé la branche début j'ai
commencé à faire le clown faire le con
mais en allant faisait d'artagnan se
servant de cette cape et je me suis
rendu compte que les enfants paient mais
il ne rie est plus du tout de la même
raison que c'est à dire qu'avant irié
contre nous et d'un seul coup ils se
sont mis à lire avec nous c'est a été
déjà quelques jeux vous êtes révolter
alors la punition été supprimés dans les
mails humiliation dans votre esprit n'a
pas été effacés non c'était pas agréable
halim un à l'étude nous font chier oui
j'aurais vérité un drame ont carrément
il ya que la récréation qui me ment elle
est parce que à la récréation de son
fait et on fait l'acteur ou les
gendarmes ce que je continue alors vous
montrer un bon rentrée comme photographe
à paris match yannick donne absolument
extraordinaire âge où vous partez en
hollande avec walter 40 d'un grand
photographe et vous partez en hollande
les digues des polders avait cédé
inondant 55 voilà et la hollande était
entièrement inondées et donc vous arrivé
là bas avec walter cajon donc faire les
photos pour match et il y avait déjà une
centaine de journalistes aaron je leur
ai dit il déballe pas ces appareils puis
il est ici très calmement et puis il me
dit guy môquet crise on assiste en
attendaient ce qui me choque des termes
t d mais trouve moi un chat un pour
moins cher alors bon je suis partie un
atelier de trouver un chat et puis il a
fallu mme amy tu vois l'arbre il y avait
un arbre au milieu de cette immense
étendue d'eau il met des fous malchance
sur la sur la route et le ch a circulé
ne fait la photo de l'enit reparti c
était la photo la plus vendue en herbe
qui a fait le tour du bourg symbole et
l'inondation de vols s'est noyé des
jeunes la mise en scène belle histoire
mais alors voilà vous faites le
photographe pour match évidemment grâce
aux relations vous aviez de par votre
famille c'est relativement facile de
faire du people oui et un jour vous
allez voir elvire popesco la grande
guerre popesco
pour match et elle vous dit pauvre con
tu ne dois pas faire ce métier de
journaliste je dois faire acteur oui
c'est d'ailleurs mon père qui m'avait
donné le curé meslier kouthia reportage
qui est intéressant à faire popesco
vient d'acheter le théâtre de paris
et elle va créer une pièce de marcel
pagnol
effectivement elle m'a engagé pour jouer
trois rôles un frère de julien
charpentier
je vais tout de suite trois répliques
ensuite passé au cinéma vous jouez dans
le pays d'où je viens de carnets et
l'équipe de tournage s'installe dans une
caserne et là les officiers vous dit bah
tu dois faire son service militaire
pourquoi tu viens pas en algérie vous
partez en algérie un peu inconsciemment
pour bien le dire tellement et là vous
découvrez une autre réalité qui est la
réalité de la guerre et vous voyez des
soldats qui font des cartons et sur ceux
qui bravent le couvre-feu
ce qui m'a le plus frappé c'est que ces
tortures étaient en général exécutés par
des appelé les militaires y avait des
gars y avait il y avait des baroudeurs
qui revenait d'indochine et qui était
assis et eux non c'était il y avait un
malin plaisir chez chez les appeler vêtu
d'un uniforme d'un seul coup un tiré
dessus puis après il va les vérifier
j'ai annoncé ma balle non c'est la
tienne annoncé mois qu'il a dû tout
nous-mêmes que brasseur un jour comme ça
vous trouve en phase
maintenant ce qu'on appelait les
fellaghas à l'époque et il va dégainer
et vous dégainez avant lui vous le tuez
exact toute la vie vous regretterez de
ne pas avoir eu la culture politique
d'être un objecteur de conscience est
vrai c'est vrai parce que génération kg
pour les jeux mon pote gilles vite chez
les oratoriens j ai effectivement
la télé la radio est formellement
interdit les seuls journaux qu'on
laissait pénétrait l'intérieur décrété
journaux sportifs et on avait
effectivement que nous qu'une aucune
culture politique jeu en sortant du
collège blanc marais capitale culturelle
dont parlait pour dieu voilà c'est ça
vous ne l'aviez pas celui là
alors votre père quand vous avez la
croix de guerre est fou de rage parce
que évidemment ça correspondait pas du
tout à ses idées il vous en veut à ce
moment là ils m'ont vu huy m'a envoyé
une lettre d excuses de quiconque va pas
porter ça
un oubli jamais que quelques secondes
près une décoration c'est une raison
funèbres voulait beaucoup vous effet le
paris dakar
vous avez jamais écraser personne
c'est un masque blair fort
soirée
ouais six fois le dakar quand même ah
ouais très sportif avoue on a besoin de
son premier faux pas oublier que dans
notre métier nous sommes à la fois
instrumentistes mais on est aussi
l'instrument vous connaissez brasseur du
puy millions d'années chez castel mieux
vous ai fait la fête ensemble olivier
tous les deux là c'est un sacré fêtard
brasseur il y toujours pâle coliques mme
breuil c'est pas du tout la même chose
donc c'est pas la musette à 70 ça c'est
pas de moi c'est une définition de
prévert et absolument j'ai fait la fête
ensemble
il est certain que vos détour de
certaines nuits nous ne croisons oui et
est toujours de façon drôle vous êtes
bien fait sauter la tête vous quand même
un oui hein
il faut dire aussi une chose c'est
difficile d'aller au lit après le
théâtre c'est un peu comme si un mec
aller se coucher à sept heures du soir
en sortant du bus à moi je sors du lot à
minuit